what i want to do in this video is come
up with an expression for finding the
sum from i equals 0
to n
of i squared so if i were to expand this
out this is equal to this is equal to
0 squared plus 1 squared plus 2 squared
plus 3 squared and we're going to keep
on going all the way to n squared so my
goal is to find some type of a function
that you give me the n and i will find
this the the sum from 0 squared 1
squared 2 squared all the way to n
squared and so you can imagine that
would be useful because this might be
okay if n is reasonably small but if n
is a big number this is going to take
you forever to do so let's first study
this let's study what kind of the input
and the output of this function needs to
be so the input is going to be our n
so here we're starting with so n can go
from zero all the way and we'll just try
up a bunch of values so n could be zero
and could be we could go from zero all
the way to zero and could be one and it
could be 2 and could be 3 and we could
just keep on going on and on and on but
i'll just stop there for now actually
let's just go to 4 just for fun and now
for each of these let's see what the
output of our function should be the
output of the function should be this
thing it should be the sum from i equals
0
to n of i squared so when n is 0 well
that's just going to be 0 squared we
just stop right over there so that's
just 0. when n is 1 it's 0 squared plus
1 squared so that is 1. when n is 2
0 squared plus 1 squared plus 2 squared
so that's 1 plus 5 or 1 plus 4 which is
5.
when n is 3 now we go all the way to 3
so it's going to be 1 plus 4 which is 5
plus 9 so 5 plus 9 is
14.
and then when n is 4 we're going to go
we're going to add the 16 4 squared to
this so this gets us to 30 and of course
we could keep going on and on and on
so let's study this a little bit to
think about what type of an ex what type
of a function we might be that might for
each of these inputs might give us this
type of an output
so let's first look at the difference
between these terms so the difference
here
is one difference here
is 4. this is obvious we added 1 here we
added 2 squared here we added 3 squared
or 9 here we added 4 squared or 16 here
and the reason why i'm doing this is if
this was a linear function then the
difference between successive terms
would be the same
now if this is a quadratic function then
the differences between the differences
would be the same let's see if that's
the case
so the difference here is one the
difference here is four
so the difference between those is three
difference here
is
is five
difference here
is seven so even the difference of the
differences is increasing but if this is
a cubic function then the differences of
the difference of the difference should
be constant so let's see if that's the
case and you'll appreciate this even
more when you start learning calculus so
let's see the difference between three
the different three and five is two the
difference between five and seven is two
and so we keep having a constant shift
of 2.
so the fact that the difference of the
difference of the difference is fixed
tells us that we should be able to
express this as some type of a cubic
function so this we could write as
this should be equal to some function in
terms of n we could write it as a
n to the third plus b
n squared plus c
times n
plus d and now we can just use the what
the inputs are and the outputs are of
these to solve for a b c and d and i
encourage you to i encourage you to to
do that
well let's first think about when n is
equal to zero
when n is equal to zero this function
evaluates to d
so this function evaluates to d
and but this but that function needs to
evaluate to zero so d needs to be zero
so i'm just trying to fix these letters
here to get the right outputs so when n
is zero this expression evaluates to d
and it needs to evaluate to zero so d
needs to be equal to zero
so d is equal to zero or we could just
ignore it so that helps us a little bit
we know from this data point we're able
to whittle it down
to it having this form right over here
and so now we can take each of these
inputs figure out what and figure out
what their corresponding output is so
let's do that i'll do that over here so
when n is one this thing evaluates to
when n is one let me just send a new
color when n is one this thing evaluates
to
a times one third to one to the third
power
which is just 1 plus b times 1 squared
which is just 1
plus c times 1 which is a c
and this needs to be equal to 1.
it needs to be equal to 1.
now when
when n is
2
when n is 2 we have a times n to the
third so that's 8 a
8
a
plus 2 squared is 4
plus 4 4b
plus 2
c
needs to be equal to 5
it needs to be equal to 5. and i need to
set up three equations if i want to
solve for three unknowns and so let's go
to three
so a times three to the q to the third
power so that's going to be 27a
27a
plus
9b
plus 9b
plus 3c
plus 3c
is going to be equal to is going to be
equal to 14. so i've set up an equation
three equations in three unknowns now i
just have to solve these for a b and c
and i will have a generalized i will
have a generalized a generalized formula
for finding the sum of the first of
finding this sum right over here this
sum of the first n squared the first n
numbers squared i guess you could call
it so what i want to do now is i'm going
to stop this video i encourage you to
try to solve the simultaneous equation
on your own in the next video i'll
actually go and solve it